jean guilhem darré bonjour bonjour
bienvenue ce matin sur rtl france alors
les mots de bruno le maire le ministre
de l'économie sont claires elle a fini
le quoi qu'il en coûte qu'est ce que
cela implique aujourd'hui pour les
indépendants
et bien pour de nombreux indépendants
s'implique beaucoup d'inquiétudes sur
sur l'avenir puisque le fonds de
solidarité était quand même un élément
important qui leur permettait
d'envisager on va dire relativement
sereinement l'avenir à ce stade nous on
est très inquiet sur sur l'avenir
notamment du commerce de proximité parce
que lorsqu'on parle de fin du fonds de
solidarité
on pense notamment aux bars ou
restaurants etc mais il ya beaucoup
d'autres secteurs d'activité comme on le
voit d'ailleurs dans votre reportage qui
sont concernés par la problématique de
la pandémie et de l'impact qu'elle a eue
sur sur l'économie globale donc il est
élu il est vrai que le changement de
pied au travers la prise en charge des
coûts fixes restent un élément
intéressant maintenant la problématique
par rapport à ça c'est que pour cette
prise en charge il est nécessaire de
faire appel à un expert comptable de
calcul et l'excédent brut d'exploitation
de transmettre ça au fisc qui va
vérifier et c'est donc on aura plusieurs
semaines de décalage d'ailleurs bruno
lemerle indiqué entre le moment de la
demande et le versement des aides
sachant que pour le ppe la vraie
problématique c'est la trésorerie s'il
n'y a pas de trésorerie on risque
d'avoir des problématiques avec la
banque avec les fournisseurs il risque
finalement de conduire à un état de
faillite faute d'avoir les aime dans des
délais suffisamment courts il ya aussi
le remboursement des pêcheurs des prêts
garantis par l'état qui doivent débuter
en mars 2022 vous parler de cette
question de trésorerie finalement à ce
qu' il y en a qui pourront pas
rembourser
dans le cas de nos enquêtes on voit
d'ores et déjà que
la très grande majorité des tpe a
sollicité le report d'un an du paiement
comme c'était possible les meilleurs de
l'année dernière donc sadc va les
obliger à payer sur quatre ans maximum
leur pg et compte tenu de l'état en
effet de l'économie au niveau des tpe et
de l'autre réseau ils n'auront pas la
possibilité
d'assumer cette charge c'est la raison
pour laquelle et bruno le maire a ouvert
la porte dans le cadre de la conférence
interministérielle d'hier donc ça c'est
un élément intéressant maintenant il
faut transformer l'essai mais l'objectif
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on puisse
augmenter de deux ans le délai pour
pouvoir payer ce pge donc on passerait
de 4 à 6 ans alors le bruno le maire qui
est assez optimiste le gouvernement en
tout cas affiché un optimisme par
rapport à la relance économique est ce
que ces petits commerces là ces petits
indépendants ils vont pouvoir bénéficier
de cette relance économique est ce que
déjà ils la sentent ou alors il ya un
décalage qui s'opère
c'est un pas intéressant puisque
effectivement bruno le maire parle
d'augmentation de la consommation etc il
indique 6% de croissance comme objectif
fin 2021
mais ce sont des chiffres généraux sont
des chiffres globaux qui cumule beaucoup
vaincu l'intégralité en définitive de
l'économie française si l'on se focalise
plus spécifiquement sur les tpe sur les
commerces de proximité
nous on se rend compte que à ce stade en
tout cas la consommation n'a pas repris
au sein de ces entreprises on est
toujours sur une tendance de -20 -30 %
de chiffre d'affaires par rapport à une
année normale donc la dernière la
dernière année malheureuse dont steve
2019 ça fait déjà deux ans et donc il
est nécessaire de maintenir pour
l'intégralité des tpe je ne parle pas
seulement des bars des restaurants de
l'événementiel du sport etc comme comme
c'est prévu à ce stade mais nécessaire
que l'intégralité des tpe qui sont
toujours impacté par la problématique de
la crise sanitaire puisse être soutenue
au travers de ce nouveau dispositif de
des coûts fixes justement vous vous
parliez
des restaurants des salles de sport n'en
parle beaucoup qui ont été impactés par
la crise mais est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
secteurs on parle un petit peu moi qui
risquent des faillites importante des
indépendants qui et qui aujourd'hui
risquent de fermer dont on parle assez
peu finalement
nous on a beaucoup suivi le secteur de
l'habillement pas ce que c'est c'est
quelque chose qui
qu'il est possible de suivre
relativement facilement au travers dans
lequel notamment dans le cadre des
différentes périodes de soldes qui ont
pu avoir lieu et on voit bien que ce
secteur souffre particulièrement
on a aussi des des entrepreneurs dont on
parle beaucoup moins parfois des me
contre entrepreneurs mais aussi des
entrepreneurs individuels notamment dans
le domaine des professionnels des
professions libérales par exemple le
conseil aux entreprises
qui qui ont perdu leurs marchés qui ont
du mal à retrouver leur clientèle ou qui
ont une clientèle plus frileuses et
qu'il continue à rencontrer des
difficultés très importantes on en
discute et le 25 août dernier dans le
cadre d'une d'une réunion qu'on a eue
avec le ministre des pme alain griset et
c'est un élément sur lequel on essaie on
essaie d'avancer sachant qu formule
aussi d'autres propositions pourquoi
soutient il ya pas qu il n'y a pas que
que le fonds de solidarité il n'y a pas
que que les aides directes si vous
voulez on peut aussi envisager par
exemple
le renouvellement du pm de l'étalement
du paiement des charges sociales le
fameux 12 24 36 mois dont qui pourrait
être renouvelée en 2022 au titre des
cotisations dues sur 2021
on pourrait aussi on pourrait aussi
envisager d'autres types d' aide dans le
cadre
notamment de de ce qui a été vu
récemment
en ce qui concerne la loi sur sur les
shalit on va dire et qui permettrait
d'avoir un abattement de charge ou un
empattement
il concerne un nombre en bourse puis
j'ai auprès des tpe merci beaucoup
jean-guilhem darré d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur les franges
rappel vous êtes délégué général du
syndicat des indépendants et des tpe